this is what the war in ukraine looks
like on one of china's most widely
followed state media accounts
the wall street journal analyzed nearly
70 ukraine related videos that were
posted since the start of the war in
february
the account has also been amplifying
russian narratives like calling the
conflict a special operation and not an
invasion
these videos also reminded followers to
watch russia's victory day parade and
the russian president appeared five
times more often than his ukrainian
counterpart
this pro-rusher perspective is just one
message that's been echoed on chinese
state media and getting shared with a
wide audience i do think that's kind of
a propaganda opportunity a persuasion
opportunity for for the chinese
government
we examine how closely chinese state
media is aligned with russia despite
beijing's efforts to present itself as a
neutral party to the war in ukraine
from day one china has an outright
condemned russia or taken part in
western sanctions against moscow
china-russia relationships has been
growing closer maria repnikova is a
political scientist fluent in russian
and chinese and she's been monitoring
how chinese state media has been
reporting on the ukraine conflict
she says their pact has gotten stronger
as both countries relationships with the
us have gotten more contentious so we
see this kind of increasing closeness of
their ties as one factor the
geopolitical relationship itself and
examining how the war is being covered
on chinese state media reveals beijing's
tilt towards russia like the people's
daily account on china's version of tick
tock
in the nearly 70 videos published on
this account which has about 150 million
followers none of them show destruction
caused by russian forces or describe how
civilians cope with the ongoing fighting
14 of the posts are clips from china's
foreign ministry which often repeats a
common line from moscow with dramatic
music
[Music]
explain pro-russia's stance is often
very much in this anti-us antenatal
rhetoric there are ten clips of putin
and they also echo a similar sentiment
[Music]
received the decision to single out
sound bites like this show a deliberate
attempt from chinese state media to
paint the west as the villains of the
ukraine crisis
meanwhile only two videos of ukrainian
president vladimir zelensky made it into
the feed and both clips show him saying
western leaders aren't doing enough
people's daily didn't respond to a
request for comment
some chinese state media organizations
have been getting specific directives on
how to cover the war two days ahead of
the invasion an online video platform
that's part of a larger state-backed
publication posted this on weibo china's
equivalent to twitter it appeared to be
instructions for its staff
the memo said posts that are unfavorable
to russia or are pro-west should not be
published
the post was later removed from weibo
the company in horizon news didn't
respond to a request for comment this
leak what it's maybe showing us isn't
going to attempt to maybe yeah we spin
this war in a particular direction
journalists in china are limited in what
they can write about which can be
observed on the country's primary
international news network
in one news report posted on cgtn's
facebook account which has more than 118
million followers two journalists
documented their journey from lev to
keith just one hour drawing from peace
they're not allowed to be maybe too
sympathetic or too pro-western or to
grow ukraine we definitely see more
debris and ruins after
brought by the conflict in crisis and
they have to kind of say it's happening
but they're not able to provide the
context or maybe include more footage of
various victims that would provide the
context
cgtn did not respond to a request for
comment
much of that context was missing from
chinese state media when mass graves
were discovered in the ukrainian town of
bucha the incident triggered global
condemnation with many countries calling
for an investigation into alleged
atrocities committed by russia
there's nothing less happening than
major war crimes responsible nations
have to come together to hold these
perpetrators accountable but the story
was largely ignored by most chinese
media outlets while the kremlin called
videos from bucha fake without
presenting any evidence to back the
claim
beijing described the images of the
civilian deaths as deeply disturbing but
warn against making quote-unquote
unfounded accusations
as the war stretches on choosing not to
condemn russia for its actions like
kombucha could put beijing in a tricky
position china still very much cares
about its relations with the west
especially for economic reasons but i
think it's very important to not
necessarily ruining this competitive
edge by over aligning with russia so
beijing has officially maintained a
neutral stance amid the war and this
diplomatic position hasn't contradicted
what's been published on state media
definitely using it as an opportunity to
assert its stance and its rise as
distinct from and arguably also counter
to the west questioning the role of the
u.s critiquing the u.s
so as long as the u.s is portrayed as a
global troublemaker the war in ukraine
remains a useful tool for russia to
justify its invasion and china to boost
its image to audiences at home and
abroad